so now here's the thing we know Danny
active you have a reputation ring lovely
to fans you very sweet you give your
time very freely to them but I read with
interest that you were starting to
toughen up now you're being a little
more discerning with your fans um admit
what what do you mean well I was her
like you were being generally nice but
you were the friend and she kind of went
you know yes right well yeah
well cuz I I think when when you like
start acting a young age people expect
you to be a total dick all the time and
that's the Handy expectation that you
sort of always find yourself coming up
against yeah and and so I think all my
life I've like been really like worked
hard to not be that and to be like as
far away that's possible but that has
sort of sometimes meant that like
someone you can be really rude to me
kind of and I'll just be like yeah fine
you know I won't really like notice that
you've been rude and sometimes like
people will come up and muck like 99% of
time when people come up to you and ask
you for something on street they are
really very nice and then just
occasionally like someone I'll come up
and I said somebody said can I get a
picture with you and I just you know
just saying words not me and Yankee but
I just said yeah of course if you want
to and she just went what wouldn't have
asked for didn't want to I was like and
of course I was like oh no of course you
wouldn't have silly of me got it
pen like she left and my girlfriend was
with me just like that guy was a dick to
you like you need so she's giving me
like a little bit of sense of like you
can judge that not gonna like a dick
back now I know I just done but you
don't need to duck
but apparently Rupert grints even worse
than you Rupert I don't know the details
of this at all but roofer ended up at
somebody's house one night just from
like continuing to say yes to think
again I feel bad saying this I feel like
someone's gonna take advantage that and
just let ask him to you know he's gonna
be like the new Manchurian Candidate
because sometimes people come up to you
and they don't mean to be rude but they
can be quite rude captain oh yeah I had
I had at the premiere of was it
suffragette my wife just been in a film
and and I thought if anybody calls out
my name algún saying autographs and as
it happened a few people saying did
another done and so this woman was
screaming screaming screaming she's
James James James I'm a dancer but same
thing my thing and then I came over and
she went oh thank you I'm a really big
fan of some of your work yeah thank you
I'll saying some of your poster okay
that was okay that was a weird and
people that are trying to be nice to try
be I think sometimes as well there's a
thing that people do where they like and
it is very particular to a particularly
young men with me want to do a thing
where they want me to know that they
don't give a [ __ ] about me like before
they start asking for something so
they'll be like didn't really like the
Harry Potter movies but can you sign
this like don't do that just say
something a nice thing it's so easy I
had one I'd one happen really recently
fancy dress party wear them and this is
weird right do you know that thing where
some people make a list of people famous
people that they're allowed to have sex
with if they meet them the free pass the
free bus right yeah she called an
allowance and that was like wallet
pocket money yeah how are you good to
spend me and so met her and her fella
and and then she came up and said
they're after a sprint so you're my
allowance and I was like a beggar Bab
excuse me and there's rent you you know
he's cool with it and you're my thing
and I was I
by the way that's a whole other story
and and I was really sort of like taken
aback right and I was I'm married and
thank you very much that's very nice she
didn't and she said this thing it was
like it was meant as a compliment
and she was trying to get me to do stuff
but it was still really backhanded and
she went cos you know a lot of girls
would be after something like Channing
Tatum do you know what y'all know
getting it achievable goals
parents are the ones who are slowly
dying and to be able to bring a smile